لم يكن هناك أي شيء صغير حول
المعركة الملحمية التي خاضها القطة بنتلي ضد
هذا الميكروويف الذي انتزعها ، لقد حركها
جسديًا ، كان من
المؤكد أن يدخلها إذا لم يكن قفل
الطفل الذي وضعه أصحابه عليه
لإبعاده عن جسده  اللغة أثناء
القيام بذلك ، لا يبدو الأمر وكأنه قطة ، فهو
يتمتع بهذه اللياقة البدنية ، فهو يشبه
الجسم الرائع باستخدام ساقيه مثل الذراعين ،
ربما يكون قد سحب الميكروويف مباشرة
من المنضدة إذا لم يتم
توصيل السلك بالكهرباء ، فلا عجب في ذلك أحيانًا.  -
قطة من شيريدان أوريغون
أصبحت فيروسية مع ملايين المشاهدات كانت
بنتلي مهووسة
بالميكروويف منذ أن تركت بريتني
بيتزا فيها ، الميكروويف
مفتوح على مصراعيه والبيتزا على الأرض
وذهبت إلى حد كبير.
قفل على خزائن المطبخ حيث
يستخدم بنتلي جميع الأرجل الأربع بدون قفل
الطفل ، سجلناه وهو يدخل
الميكروويف في ثماني ثوانٍ مسطحة.تقول
بريتاني إن الجهاز هو أفضل
صديق له ، هل كانت هناك أي مكالمات قريبة
حيث قمت تقريبًا بالضغط على الطباخ يا إلهي
الخير ، لم يكن هناك عدد مفاجئ من الأشخاص
في الفيديو يخبرونني بإغلاق
الباب ، هذه القصة تذكرني بواحدة
فعلتها قبل 27 عامًا حول جحر الثور الخنزير
الذي دخل إلى الثلاجة ، وفي كثير من الأحيان
كان على مالكه أن يبقيه مغلقًا ثم
ألتصق  من خلال الفتحة ولكن عندما يكون
القط مقابل الميكروويف أحيانًا
يحرك القط الجهاز وأحيانًا
يحركه الجهاز
OS CNN New York